trade investment employment
infrastructure key issues for the
European Union and Africa with the
potential to bring tremendous prosperity
to people on both continents more than a
quarter of total african trade takes
place with the EU as europe opens up
markets in many sectors to its dynamic
neighbour even amid the global downturn
african economic growth has been
impressive eight of the ten fastest
expanding economies in the world are
African but also 24 of the 25 poorest
countries to address the challenges
Africa's striving to create the right
environment for private sector
investment with encouragement from
Europe investing is a key theme we want
to unlock the entrepreneurial potential
of people both in Europe particularly in
Africa there are people with tremendous
energy very large young population and
put to work they will help generate the
growth on top of trade well integrated
regional markets with strong
infrastructure could attract investment
encourage business to develop create
jobs and improve access to quality goods
and services when it comes to trade and
investment Africa says we are open for
business but we are not for sale another
major challenge this century is to
ensure effective and reliable energy
suppliers in Africa in Baneen the
president of the european council takes
part in the laying of the first stone in
a joint project that will help West
Africa better share its power supplies
through the Africa EU energy partnership
work is progressing to improve access to
cheap reliable climate-friendly
sustainable energy for both continents
infrastructure is the foundation of much
of Africa's improved growth and has the
potential to contribute more the EU in
Africa cooperate to boost investment in
it but also in services and regulatory
reform and things like water
and sanitation projects and roads and of
course Europe remains Africa's biggest
development partner investing some 18
billion euros last year alone other
shared initiatives include the anti
conflict diamond forum the kimberley
process and the management of Natural
Resources like forests